at some point almost every gamer on the
planet has thought to themselves what
the hell is vsync depending on the game
there can be loads of different
graphical settings but vsync is one
that's always there but what does it
actually do and should you have yours on
or off well vsync or vertical
synchronization is a setting that syncs
the game's frame rate to the refresh
rate of your monitor the point of this
is to eliminate screen tearing which is
when your display is split showing two
frames at once this happens when the GPU
renders more frames than your monitor
can display but if the game you're
playing has a low frame rate or you have
a capable Monitor and GPU having vsync
on can unnecessarily cap your FPS worst
case scenario during graphically intense
moments where your frame rate does drop
vsync will think it needs to match the
two which can lead to some pretty
distracting results given how powerful
today's monitors are I recommend leaving
vsync off by default unless you find
that you're getting screen tearing we
talked more about vsync in our cracked
episode about refresh rates so if you
want more info then make sure to check
that video out